well hello there we're going to talk
about abortion
and sex in hollywood and lots of things
having to do with trump and dead
soldiers and all sorts of stupid things
also i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
little behind the scenes there every
time we open this show i have to look to
a different camera and i am very awkward
at it so if you can't see the show
that's what you're missing out on folks
okay so
before we get to any of these things so
somebody on the left this morning on
twitter presented the greatest
pro-abortion argument of all time uh
and then i refuted it and then he
blocked me so i will explain to you why
this was not in fact the greatest
pro-abortion argument of all time
and why it is that people think it was
we'll also
talk a little bit more about the metoo
hashtag that is going around all these
women posting on social media
about how they've been sexually harassed
in the past which is fine and dandy but
i
do have a couple of questions that i
think need to be answered if we're going
to actually
do something practical with all that
information plus president trump goes
after president obama for
not caring about dead troops or
something which is just
awesome we'll get to all of that but
first i want to say thank you to our
sponsors
over at legacy box so if you are a
person who wants to preserve your
memories
are you going to preserve your childhood
memories you want to make sure that all
those boxes of old films that are
moldering out in the garage
those don't go to waste you want to make
sure that your parents have access to
those things
this is why you need a legacy box we all
have these things sitting in the garage
and then there's we don't care about
them for years we let them
gather dust and there's spiders and it's
gross and then there's a fire and we run
out there and we grab the box that is
covered in
dust mites and we bring it outside to
the car and it turns out we don't have
enough room and the pictures are
waterlogged
don't be that person that's why you need
legacy box legacy box
is a simple affordable way to get your
recorded moments digitally preserved on
dvd or thumb drive here's how it works
so
you get a box in the mail from legacy
box then you send back all your old
tapes films pictures audios
audio recordings there's a little bar
code that you can slap on each item so
you know where it is in the process
they take all of those things they
upload them they clean them up and they
put them on a dvd or a thumb drive for
you
so now everything is available to you
you can put it on your computer it's
digitally available
and you no longer have to worry about
those boxes and boxes of garbage that
are in your garage that are not really
garbage they're actually important
family memories
legacy box takes care of everything it
is an awesome service go to
legacybox.com
ben get a 40 discount on your order
right now so great deal legacybox.com to
get that 40 discounts on your order i
think it's a wonderful
gift for mom or dad particularly so if
you have a parent who's having a
birthday or mother's day father's day
is coming up this is the best time to do
a great christmas gifts as well
legacybox.com
get a 40 discount on your order uh it's
again i think a very important service
actually okay so
we begin today with an argument that was
going around twitter this morning i woke
up
and there was a tweet storm that was
going around it has now been
liked almost 19 000 times and retweeted
9 000 times it's a big tweet right
especially from a guy
who no one's ever heard of this guy's
name is patrick tomlinson i would tell
you how many followers he has except
that he blocked me
so patrick tomlinson is apparently the
author of something called the ark
trilogy he's a sci-fi
author calls himself a comic i'm going
to read you his nasty
little his nasty little tweet storm and
then i'm going to explain why it is so
appealing on the surface to pro choices
and then i'm going to explain why it
makes no sense so
here is his argument in favor of
abortion and it just drips with
condescension and disdain anyone who
disagrees with him as a fool and a liar
i'm so sick of that attitude i really am
if i haven't made that clear with regard
to jimmy kimmel i'm gonna make it clear
now with regard to patrick tomlinson
here's what he tweeted quote
whenever abortion comes up i have a
question i've been asking for 10 years
now if the life begins at conception
crowd
in 10 years no one has ever answered it
honestly
then he says it's a simple scenario with
two outcomes wow i mean just
the brilliance this guy must carry in
his head it's just mind-boggling
no one ever wants to pick one because
the correct answer destroys their
argument
there is a correct answer which is why
the pro-life crowd hates the question
here it is are you ready so good you're
in a fertility clinic
why isn't important the fire alarm goes
off you run for the exit as you run down
the hallway you hear a child screaming
from behind a door
you throw open the door and find a
five-year-old child crying for help
exciting no
they're in one corner of the room in the
other corner is
there by the way spelled t-h-e-y
apostrophe r-e
the genius writer knows they're in one
corner of the room
in the other corner you spot a frozen
container labeled 1 000 viable human
embryos
the smoke is rising you start to choke
you know you can grab one or the other
but not both before you succumb to smoke
inhalation and die saving no one
do you a save the child or b save the
thousand embryos
there is no c c means you all
die
he says in a decade of arguing with
anti-abortion people about the
definition of human life
i have never gotten a single straight a
or b answer to this question
and i never will they will never answer
honestly because we all instinctively
understand the right answer is a
a human life is worth more than a
thousand embryos or ten thousand or a
million
because they are not the same not
morally not ethically not biologically
this question absolutely eviscerates
their argument
and their refusal to answer confirms
that they know it to be true no one
anywhere actually believes an embryo is
equivalent to a child that person does
not exist they are
lying to you they are lying to you to
try and evoke an emotional response
a paternal response using false
equivalency no one believes life begins
at conception
no one believes embryos are babies or
children those who claim to
are trying to manipulate you so they can
control women don't let them
use this question to call them out
reveal them for what they are demand
they answer your question and when they
don't
slap that big ol scarlet p of the
patriarchy on them
the end wow mine
blown just amazing i mean
just the other genius of this guy if i
thought of this example like
i thought of this hypothetical stupid
question like i don't know 10 years ago
totally would have changed my worldview
i would voted for hillary clinton and
i'd be wearing a sticker
uh with a hat on it okay so let's
put aside the fact that this guy's
obviously a douchebag
the the commenters on the twitter thread
are properly puzzled the reason they're
properly puzzled is because
he is correct that your moral intuition
suggests that you save the five-year-old
child
and not the box marked 1000 viable
embryos here is why this does not prove
the point he thinks that approves there
are many reasons why this has not
even come close to proving the point he
thinks it proves he thinks this proves
that human embryos aren't life
he thinks that this proves that we are
all liars when we say that human embryos
are human life
he says that this proves that human
embryos are not babies
uh he says that this proves that we are
all liars okay so here is why this is
not true
in any sense so here are four reasons
first
moral instinct does not always mean you
thought things through so we have lots
of moral instincts
those moral instincts may be good they
may be right they may be wrong
that does not provide a moral logic okay
just because you have a moral feeling
does not mean that the logic is well
thought out
so for example here's another famous
thought experiment i love thought
experiments i think they're fun
so that's why i'm focusing on this
because i think that it's good for you
to get better at dot experiments
and it's fun for me to go through them
so here's another famous thought
experiment this of course is the trolley
problem everyone has
knows of the trolley car problem this is
where
you are standing on a railroad track at
trolley car track
and the track is right at the fork okay
you're standing right at the fork
it goes to the right and it goes to the
left on the left there is nell who is
tied to the track
and on the right there are five people
who are tied to the track
okay do you pull the switch and switch
the trolley car from the one that is
going to kill
the five people to the one that is just
going to kill mel most people say yes
right okay pretty easy answer right this
utilitarian answer we will save the five
instead of saving the one okay now here
is the more famous trolley car
question you are now standing on a
bridge over the trolley car track
and on the track is titan l and five
other peoples there's six people tied to
the trolley car track
you're standing above on a bridge and up
next to you is standing michael moore
okay some big fatso now do you if you
take michael moore and you push him over
the side of the bridge
and the trolley car is stopped by the
weight of the
of his grease against the skids do you
throw michael moore over the top of the
bridge
most people say no most people say
there's a moral difference between me
throwing a switch
and me pushing somebody physically off a
bridge to their doom
that's a moral intuition but can you
justify it the answer is probably not
and what this demonstrates is that most
people's moral intuition
is not necessarily a thought through
logic and let's give another example
okay we can give all sorts of these
thought experiments proving that the
moral intuition goes the other way so
for example
let's say that instead of a
five-year-old in a box of one thousand
random viable embryos it was a box of
two embryos
and they were your children right you
were infertile and your wife was
infertile but somehow through a miracle
they've created two embryos that are
your children your only possibility of
having children and they are viable so
we know that they will implant and be
fine right that's the premise of this
question
so do you save the embryos or you save
the five-year-old the random
five-year-old
a lot of people would say save the
embryos now because they're your
children that's a moral intuition
doesn't make it right
i assume tomlinson would say no it's
just because you had a moral feeling one
way or another doesn't mean that the
feeling
is justified and let's make it even
easier okay let's say that you have your
five-year-old right it's your child and
it's a five-year-old now right it's my
daughter and she's three and a half
years old
and in the next room there are a hundred
screaming adults and i can only save one
right who do i say my three and a half
year olds are the hundred screaming
adults
most parents would say they would save
their three and a half year old does
that make that a moral choice
okay this is the premise of every 24
episode ever right it's always kim bauer
that idiot getting captured
and then jack has to decide whether to
save the entire city of los angeles or
his dumb ass daughter
right it's like it's the premise to
every ticking bomb thriller is
do you i mean it's it's spider-man right
mary jane is falling off and spider-man
has to save mary jane or he can save the
bus full of screaming children
which does he choose and naturally the
producers allow him to get away with
saving both
but his tendency is to save mary jane
right
does that make it immoral does that is
that a moral decision or is it just a
moral impetus so just because you feel
like you want to save the five-year-old
that doesn't necessarily mean that
you're correct
okay second point on this stupid
hypothetical
it doesn't actually reveal the value of
embryonic life so
we can agree with tomlinson that you you
should save the five-year-olds rather
than the box of embryos on a moral level
and still that would not admit that
embryonic life is meaningless it would
just mean that you care more about the
five-year-old life than you care about
the embryonic life
whether they're viable or not in fact we
can imagine a counter scenario where you
care more about the embryonic life than
the five-year-old so let's take a sci-fi
scenario since tomlinson is a sci-fi
writer
let's take the the sort of battlestar
galactica scenario
okay the fate of humanity rests on this
one box
full of 1000 embryos that have males and
females in them
and now there's a fire on your spaceship
and you can save a screaming
five-year-old
the only child or right it's just you
and the five-year-old there are no other
people
alive right it's ju that's the end of
the human story you can save those 1000
embryos
and you can and you can ensure that they
are born from artificial wombs and they
will live and create a new human species
or you can save this one five-year-old
and you can both die alone in the middle
of space
which do you do right so again every
sci-fi movie ever says you save the box
of embryos does that mean
that the five-year-old is no longer a
human life right because what he's doing
is he's creating a false binary and then
saying whichever one you choose the
other one's not a human life i've just
given you a bunch of false binaries and
then said
whichever one you choose is still a
human life so clearly that isn't true
i want to give you the rest of the
argument in just a second but first
i want to say thank you to our friends
over at framebridge.com so
if you need to frame your photos if you
are on snapchat or instagram if you have
a bunch of photos on your phone you
don't know what to do with them and
they're just going to disappear into the
ether but you know that they look great
on your wall the best thing to do is go
over to framebridge.com it's what i do
we've used it for photos
from my family we'll do so again and
that's because they are awesome
you upload your photo from your computer
or directly from your instagram feed or
if you have a physical item they will
provide secure prepaid packaging so you
can ship it to them for free
and then you can preview your photo
online in any frame style choose your
favorite or get free help from their
talented designers
instead of the hundreds you'd pay at a
framing store for a custom frame their
prices start at 39 bucks and all the
shipping is free
the expert team at frame bridge again
they custom frame it it is ready to hang
at your door in days
it is uh it is just a great service
framebridge.com use the promo code
superior you get 15
off your first order again promo code
shapiro at framebridge.com
and you get 15 off your first order by
the way they give a happiness guarantee
so if you don't like it
then they will make it right again
framebridge.com use promo code shapiro
save an additional 15
off your first store it's already
cheaper than you get at one of these
other frame retail frame stores go to
framebridge.com
use that promo code shapiro and that
will allow you to get 15
off they're already inexpensive uh but
quality
wear okay framebridge.com check that out
promo code shapiro so they know we sent
you okay so
next point on this on this idiotic
argument that the left thinks destroys
all of the all of the various uh
arguments in favor of the pro-life
movement
okay most pro-lifers already acknowledge
that an already born
human life takes priority over a not yet
born human life
how do we know this because the vast
majority the vast majority of religions
in fact all that i know of including
catholic doctrine say that if you have
to choose between the life of the mother
and the life of the unborn child you
choose the life of the mother
this is in catholic doctrine to give a
perfect example from catholic doctrine
because catholic catholics are most
strict on this
the doctrine is let's say that you're a
woman and you have uterine cancer
and chemo and surgery are the only way
to prevent you from dying from the
uterine cancer
and the side effect of the chemo is that
it's going to kill the embryo are you
allowed to get the chemo catholic
doctrine says
absolutely and the doctor didn't do
anything wrong why because we value the
life of the mother
and you are not actively killing the
child you are passively killing the
child
it's it's a it's it's a secondary effect
of the chemo that you're trying to do to
save a life the same exact premise
applies
in this particular hypothetical that
tomlinson puts forward and finally
the hypothetical isn't reality okay this
is the part that's the stupidest
i'm not even arguing with the
hypothetical now the hypothetical is
saying
five-year-old child versus embryos
choose um
when women get abortions they don't have
a choice between five-year-old child and
the embryo they are just choosing to
kill the embryo
an abortion doctor doesn't have a
five-year-old child with a gun to their
head in the next room and says ah save
that five-year-old
i'm gonna kill this baby now instead the
doctor just says
would you like to kill the baby and the
woman says yes and they're done
so the so it doesn't hold in any way but
this is what the left likes to do they
pose false hypotheticals that don't
actually prove their point and then they
say
if you answer me you've proved my point
well i answered him
i'd save the five-year-old it still
didn't prove his point for all the
reasons that i just said
um so i said all of this on twitter and
then he basically accused me of being
gay and blocked me so
well done patrick tomlinson uh you've
demonstrated
fully how genius you are no one could
give you a straight answer
you are just a an epic intellect uh i'm
i'm
stunned by the the fact that no one has
taken
uh taken your genius at face value okay
so in other news um there's this this
hashtag that's going around on social
media me too uh and there are people
that i know members of my family have
posted
on this hashtag metoo about being
sexually harassed at work
sexual harassment is awful sexual
harassment is evil it's why i am
supremely careful
around women uh i do not i think that
you know touching at the office is
inappropriate uh i think that
you know the the only person of the
opposite sex that you should be touching
other than a handshake
uh is your spouse this is my view of the
matter as a general matter and it's
funny because the same people who will
claim sexual harassment and yell sexual
harassment say that i'm approved for
saying stuff like this
i'm approved for saying that you
shouldn't touch other people at the
office ooh prude but then if you touch
somebody else at the office
then they say well that could be sexual
harassment okay you can't have it both
ways
okay you can't rip on mike pence for
being super careful at the office and
then suggest
that mike pence uh is sexually harassing
a woman if he if he touches her on the
shoulder
now you can't say that joe biden is
doing just fine every time he gives some
random lady a shoulder rob
but mike pence is totally wrong every
time he says he's not going to touch
anybody but his wife
um one of the problems that i have with
the metoo thing is this
um there are a lot of people who are
hashtagging me too and telling their
stories of sexual harassment um and
sexual
assault we need to have some standards
the reason i say this is not because i
don't think it's valuable when women
talk about their experiences it's fine
for women to talk about their
experiences it's good and i think men
should be very aware
of the fact that women are not going to
like it always when they go in for a hug
when they give them a kiss on a cheek or
when they give them a shoulder rub or
any of this kind of stuff right men
should be aware of all of these things
and be supremely careful
as i suggest however one of the things
that i have a problem with
is the supposed heroism of all of these
actresses who are now coming out and
claiming that they were sexually
assaulted but will not name their
accuser so reese witherspoon came out
and she's a huge star right one of
hollywood's biggest stars she says that
she was sexually assaulted in 16.
she says that uh this is this is what
she said
during her speech at l women in
hollywood she said quote
this has been a really hard week for
women in hollywood for women all over
the world and a lot of situations and a
lot of industries are forced to remember
and relive a lot of ugly truths
i've had my own experiences that come
back to me very vividly and i find it
hard to sleep hard to think hard to
communicate a lot of the feelings i've
been having
about anxiety honest honesty the guilt
for not speaking up earlier says i feel
true disgust at the director who
assaulted me
when i was 16 years old and anger at the
agents and producers who made me feel
that silence was a condition of my
employment
and i wish i could tell you that was an
isolated incident in my career but sadly
it wasn't
i've had multiple experiences of
harassment and sexual assault and i
don't speak about them very often
here's the problem we have to have some
lines here
okay we have to know what it is that it
is worth
people losing their jobs and their
career is over and
what it is that is inappropriate and if
people are not told
where the line is how do you expect them
to abide by the line so you can use my
line right my line is you don't get to
touch a woman at the office
without her permission ever right and if
you do and if you do that
then you are in serious trouble right
that is sexual harassment
uh you're doing it without consent
however that is not what modern
leftist society has said on sex right
modern leftist society has said for
decades on sex
that sexual looseness at the office is
actually a good thing maybe
the woman would like i mean let's not
pretend that romances have not started
at the office because a huge number of
people
are currently living together who met at
the office and started going out
and the way that human touch works is
not always
a guy with the checklist coming up and
saying i need you to check every one of
these boxes right when somebody makes a
move
it's very easy to do this in the
abstract but when somebody makes a move
very often it is not a move where
somebody says is it okay right now if i
kiss you is it okay if i touch your
shoulder okay that's
generally not how it happens as far as
i'm aware and i'll appeal to the female
in the room and make her quite awkward
now
jess do you believe that this is the way
that it works in human relationships
that guys typically ask girls before
they kiss them can i kiss you or hold
your hand
or have you had experiences where a guy
has just made a move on you and it
hasn't been the end of the world
right it's 50 50 and this is sort of the
problem right is that there's no hard
lines with regard to this stuff
and there are times when a guy will make
a move on a girl and the girl is totally
fine with it and there are times when a
guy will make a move on a girl and she's
totally not fine with it
and because there's no hard line on this
stuff it's hard to know for a lot of
guys
where exactly to draw the line now we
can say as i would say
that the guy should ask consent always
before kissing right when
when i first kissed my wife that's
actually what i did i said do you mind
if i kiss you now
which is not the most romantic thing to
do but that's how i operate
um but that is not always how human
relationships work and so i'm seeing a
lot of stories
online and in these metoo circles that
don't actually draw the hard line like
would you report a guy for he's drunk at
a party and he and he tries to kiss you
would you report a guy to hr for that is
that worth the guy losing his job
someone would say yes someone would some
women would say no
we need to have some hard lines of
society and figure out where the line is
actually drawn
right apparently the line isn't even
drawn at actual sexual assault in
hollywood
right these women america ferreira says
that she was sexually assaulted at the
age of nine
she says first time i can remember being
sexually assaulted i was nine years old
i told no one and lived with the shaman
guilt thinking all along that i a
nine-year-old child was somehow
responsible for the actions
of a grown man i had to see this man on
a daily basis for years to come
he would smile at me wave and i would
hurry past him my blood running cold my
guts carrying the burden of what he only
he and i knew that he expected me to
shut my mouth
and smile back right alissa milano is
saying some of the same stuff america
is a big girl now okay like i understand
when you're nine years old not speaking
out about that i get it i understand the
pressure i understand the horror
i can never fully understand because i
wasn't in that position but i
i get where she's coming now she's an
adult that guy is still preying on young
children presumably
why doesn't she say his name so in
hollywood they won't even say the names
okay this is the same problem i have
with the institutional racism
argument is there racism in american
society yes i need a specific name and a
specific example so i can fight it with
you
i need a specific instance with a
specific name so i can fight it with you
or decide whether you are just being
oversensitive
with regards to the metoo stuff i want
to be on your side
i want to say let's put this rapist in
jail i want to say let's put this sexual
harasser in jail or allow you to assume
but i don't think that we have any hard
standards with regards to this stuff
like i was telling my wife about this
last night
my wife is a very beautiful woman uh and
she's been hit on a lot in her life
as a doctor she gets hit on a lot right
she experiences stuff i'm sure male
doctors don't where patients will hit on
her on a pretty regular basis
like there is the example that she gave
is she was working at the veterans
administration
and one guy said to her this is like an
older guy probably 60 years old said to
her something like
your eyes are so blue and so deep
they're like the ocean
and she was like should i have been
insulted by that or should i been sort
of complimented by that
i chose to be sort of complimented by it
but i could see being insulted by it
and that's sort of right right the the
problem with a lot of this sort of stuff
is it's i know when i see it now i think
there are some
obvious hard wines that are pretty clear
and this is why i'm very frustrated with
these actresses who are now big stars
and who are leaving predators in
positions of power
by not naming names there is no statute
of limitations to child molestation
okay but the but the fact that that is
not what's happening is a problem
and again i think that we're all on the
same side i think that when we are vague
about these things it actually creates
false divisions that don't exist i think
all good hearted people want to see men
who sexually harassed
called out i think that we need hard
standards of what sexual harassment
constitutes
what sexual assault constitutes and it
can't just be
that something bothered me 10 years ago
i said nothing about it i come out today
i
give a vague reference to being sexually
harassed at work and then we're all
supposed to just say well that's society
yes men should be careful yes men should
know
as i say hold by my standard i like my
standard the best but since as a society
we have not decided to abide by my
standard apparently
since we've decided that it's prudish to
abide by mike pence's standard
then i don't know what standard we are
supposed to abide by and i would like
for all uh
this is not a critique this is all of us
coming together and creating a formal
societal standard where we know what's
good and what's bad so that we can
target the bad guys i don't see why
that's too much to ask
that's not the metoo campaign that is
saying when you say me too
how about you say who did it and what it
was so that we can determine whether it
was something bad enough that the person
should lose their job lose their career
lose their livelihood and go to jail
is that unreasonable if we're going to
accuse people of crimes maybe we should
accuse people of crimes
okay so before i go any further along
these lines i also want to talk about
some stuff that president trump said
first i want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at blinkist so
you don't have any time today you don't
have any time you're going to be in the
car for 15 minutes today you love to
read you love to gain information and
my podcast has already ended and now you
have 15 minutes so what do you do what
do you do
well if we're not living in an abortion
hypothetical what you actually do is you
go over to blinkist.com
ben and there you download all of their
books because what they do
is they summarize the main points of all
of the best-selling books
in the non-fiction world it's really
terrific it's a way for you to learn
listen i read books incessantly i read
books all the time
i'll read a 600 page book and if you ask
me to give you 15 minutes of material on
the book i probably could not
that is why blinkist is so great it
summarizes all of these main points of
the book
so that you know them without actually
having to spend the 10 hours reading the
book
that you actually might need to read a
500 page book
the blinkist app has 2000 of the
best-selling non-fiction books
transformed into these powerful packs
that you can listen to
in just 15 minutes they're really well
done i've listened to many of them
it is a top app over at apple for a
reason
you can learn essential ideas in a very
short period of time you can be in the
car for an hour and basically read four
books it's fantastic
it's blinkist b-l-i-n-k-i-s-t dot com
slash ben
and when you go to slash ben you get
your free trial and that free trial is
uh
is for our audience right now so you can
check it out and you can and you can see
how great it is
or you can get three months off of your
yearly plans you can join for a year and
you get three months off of the yearly
plans you get it for for cheaper
at blinkist.com ben again it's
blinkist.com
ben it's pretty awesome and some of the
books that are on there
many books that i've read and spent
hours reading things like flow the power
of habit
drive rich dad poor dad smarter faster
better
you know all of these self-help books
pop sociology books that i really enjoy
plus actual hard history books uh things
like
why nations fail it's a 600 page book
you can get in 15 minutes over at
blinkist.com so blinkist.com and you get
either that free trial or
three months off your yearly plan when
you join today go check it out and make
yourself smarter
okay so again final word on the metoo
thing just to reiterate
i think it's good that women are calling
out sexual harassment in the workplace
i think in order for us to fight sexual
harassment in the workplace two things
have to happen i think me too does one
thing but it doesn't do the other
me too makes men aware that they need to
be careful around women as well they
should
but what it does not do is it allows us
it does not allow us to actually target
the guys who have already done bad stuff
and should have known better
in order for that to happen you have to
name names and you have to name
scenarios and we need to know
what constitutes the line that was
crossed right like
i i can't help feeling that some of this
is politicized again i mentioned joe
biden
look at those pictures of joe biden
being really awkward around women
okay and and let me ask how many
democrats are willing for to say that
joe biden should not run for president
or should not have been a senator
or should not have been vp i mean for
goodness sake the
the right decided it was fine for trump
to be president and the left decided it
was fine for clinton to be president and
both of them have some
pretty nasty histories with regards to
this sort of stuff
uh okay so uh when i i also want to talk
today
um about the trump versus bannon war
supposedly
uh over establishment versus
non-establishment i don't think that
really
exists before i get to that i want to
talk a little bit about a comment that
president trump made that is getting all
sorts of play today so yesterday
president trump did
a press conference and at this press
conference he did what he is fond of
doing
uh he said something off the cuff that
is that is kind of that is pretty dumb
he was trying to demonstrate that he
really loves the troops
now president trump is the kind of
fellow who likes to say that everything
that he does is unprecedented
right if he went to the bathroom he
didn't just have a bowel movement he had
the greatest bowel movement in history
no one has ever had a better bell
movement people it is the grip no one no
genghis khan had never no one okay like
it's andre the andre the giant has never
had a bowel movement
of this bag it was huge huge right so
this is just how everything is phrased
for president trump
he's the only one who's ever done
anything right every hurricane is
unprecedented
every attack is is unprecedented
everything he does is the greatest the
best the the brightest the most
incredible
the most beautiful the most wonderful
the worst the most horrible
he he only speaks in superlatives it's
something i've critiqued before well
because of that
he gets himself into some hot water so
yesterday he was talking about how he
calls the families of fallen troops and
just by the wayside he says
and i'm basically the only guy who's
ever done that sort of thing here's
president trump saying exactly
that this is him saying that president
obama did not call the troops clip 8.
the traditional way if you look at
president obama and
other presidents most of them didn't
make calls a lot of them didn't make
calls
i like to call when it's appropriate
when i think i'm
able to do it okay so a lot of them
didn't make calls i'm the only one who
makes calls
that's the implication uh and then the
white house defended by saying well it's
true that not all
parents of troops were called that's
really not what trump is saying can we
all see what the implication is what
trump
is saying there and now the white house
because everything that trump says has
to be doubled down upon
it's really uh it's kind of gross so now
the white house is saying
that president obama did not call
general john kelly the chief of staff
whose son died in afghanistan in 2010
they're saying obama didn't call kelly
so now john kelly's going to be dragged
into this thing
again the easiest thing to say here is
president trump
misspoke of course other presidents
called the families of fallen troops
i think people who are on obama's team
are right to be angry about this because
that is something that obama apparently
did do
um but it's also the sort of thing where
because the media is going to jump on it
a lot of people on the right are going
to claim that it's unfair the the media
always has to overstep instead of making
the critique that i just made
that trump always speaks like this he
speaks in superlatives that puts him in
a position of saying things that are not
true
um and uh and frankly uh disingenuous
that instead of just saying that instead
they have to go completely overboard
trump's scum
trump's a cockroach trump's the worst
guy in the world cnn's philma did
exactly that last night
boy it's a tough date for the president
how about for the families who accepted
a child or a father or spouse home in a
casket
it's not a tough day for them this guy
has the empathy of a cockroach
from the day after his inauguration when
he showed up at my agency by former
agency the cia
in front of the wall of fallen heroes
and spoke about the size of his
inauguration fast forwarding now what is
it nine months and he can't figure out
his responsibility not only as the
commander-in-chief
but as the consular in chief is to tell
those families it's not about me it's
not about donald trump
it's about 330 million americans saying
thank you for having someone like that
this sort of talk is not helpful to the
other side so i mean i don't give
advice to people who are on the
democratic left but let me give you a
little piece of advice here
it is not helpful to the american
experiment for you to suggest that trump
now trump has no no sympathy for the
fallen soldiers
right what you can say is that trump is
overstepping what you can say is that
trump lied about president obama what
you can say is that trump is
mean when he says that about president
obama it is wrong for him to impute that
sort of motivation to president obama
but to go to he has no empathy at all
for the fallen troops is you now
overstepping in the other direction
right and this is every every
controversy is now this
trump says something wrong the left
oversteps way too far in the other
direction
the right oversteps way too far in the
opposite direction and nobody actually
ends up in
in the place where the truth is right
the truth is trump said something that
is wrong and false and nasty
and instead of just saying this is wrong
and false and nasty people immediately
go to well he hates the troops
like really that's where you want to go
that's the place that you want to go
i i don't see why they why people do
that at all and it's because of that
reactionary tendency and politics that
president trump won really
like people say how could he win in
spite of saying things like this it's
not in spite of saying things
like this it's because he said things
like this and the right inherently
believes that
there are a lot of people on the left
who don't care enough about fallen
troops because it's always easy to
impute bad motivations to the other side
and then the left immediately claims
that trump doesn't care about the fallen
troops and the right says well screw
you right this is how the game was
played okay and i'll show you the proof
right so here is president trump
yesterday
this is the part about why trump won
okay so president trump won because he
was running against hillary clinton
end of story okay hillary clinton won
the presidency for donald trump there's
a
hilarious piece by governor newsweek
saying here's how we could still make
hillary clinton president
uh or i think the actual title was
here's how hillary clinton can still
enter the oval office
and i tweeted she can she can wrap
herself in a box and mail herself there
i mean that's that's the only way that
she's gonna get in but in any case
you know trump says and he's correct
that hillary who's been very supportive
of these people kneeling for the
national anthem
in the nfl that's why she lost when you
take in a she well that's why she lost
the election
i mean honestly it's that thinking that
is the reason she lost the election
when you go down and take a knee or
any other way you're sitting essentially
for our great national anthem you're
disrespecting our flag
and you're disrespecting our country
okay so he's right about this and this
is why hillary clinton is not the
president today
it's this reactionary stuff right
hillary clinton feels like she has to
react to trump so she sides with the nfl
players and then trump smacks her
this is why trump is president and
hillary clinton is not and this is why
he
begged her basically esther this is
actually kind of funny he begged her to
run again yesterday
oh i hope hillary runs is she going to
run i hope hillary please run again go
ahead
okay again that's you know that is that
is certainly
what he desperately hopes okay so let's
talk uh a little bit
about the the other the other sort of
controversy that broke out around
president trump yesterday this is the
one that's making all the headlines the
reason i didn't start the show with this
is because
i think it's really overblown and i will
explain in just a second but first i
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at zeal so one of the things i
always say on the show is there are some
things in life where you don't have to
spend a lot of money to feel like a
wealthy person
one of those things is a great massage
okay you don't have to spend a ton of
money
and that is certainly true over at zeal
so
zeal is a service that actually sends a
masseuse to your home they bring the
table
they bring the oils they bring the
soothing music and they turn your house
basically into a spa
it is fantastic i've used it personally
my wife has used it
both my parents have used it my in-laws
have used it my sister has used it this
is a service that
it makes for a fantastic gift for if you
just want to surprise somebody um
then send a masseuse to them uh as a
gift and there's nothing more relaxing
so zeal is just fantastic i think 9 000
licensed masseuses with a massage table
and music and everything
just fantastic and again you don't have
to make these reservations like days in
advance okay sometimes it's like an
hour in advance go over to zeel.com and
that's where you can make
these reservations and right now to help
you get started our listeners get 25
25 rather off their first massage by
using the promo code ben
at checkout get 25 bucks off your first
massage when you use promo code ben
at checkout it's z-e-e-l right z-e-e-l
dot com
or you can get zeal's iphone or android
app and make sure you click to add promo
code at checkout and use my code ben get
off your first in-home on-demand massage
by the way if you sign up for their
massage membership you get 20
off all your massages plus a free
massage table and a sheet set
that's a 380 value yours for free and
there's no initiation fee
to join the membership just this great
additional savings on top of the 25
discount you're gonna get when you use
promo code ben again use promo code ben
and you can either get that 25 off your
first massage or you can get 20 percent
off all massages plus a free massage
table and sheet set
380 380 value yours free when you get a
zeal massage membership again that's
z-e-e-l-dot-com
z-e-l.com or their iphone or android app
and use promo code ben
at checkout it really is top-notch stuff
it's really fantastic okay so
yesterday the war broke out between
steve bannon and donald trump now the
reason i make light of this
is because i don't actually think steve
bannon is a particularly important
figure
steve bannon is a proxy for the the
money of robert and rebecca mercer
right that's all okay steve bannon is
their political guru
the mercers spend a lot of money on
politics they spend a lot of money on
ted cruz and donald trump
in the last election cycle and so they
are funding some of the people that
bannon says that they should fund
now what bannon is smart about is he's
not gonna pick uh
i don't think he's gonna make the
mistake anymore of picking
primary challengers who are bad
candidates or who don't already have
momentum
or who wouldn't win anyway in other
words i think that trump is going to
pick winners
uh and i think i mean bannon is going to
pick winners and then he's going to
claim that he is responsible for their
victory that's basically what happened
in alabama so bannon went down to
alabama he campaigned for roy moore over
luther strange
in the republican primary down there roy
moore is going to win anyway roy moore
is one of the most famous people in
alabama politics
i knew his name long before he was
running for senate
uh in fact if we want to be specific
about this breitbart i believe
backed the guy who finished third in the
original primary uh they backed
a a congress person who finished behind
both luther strange
and roy moore in that primary uh down in
alabama in the first round
uh and then they backed roy moore and
supposedly was breitbart that drove him
to victory or bannon that drove him to
victory
i don't think that's right i think
bannon is smart enough to jump on a
bandwagon that's already moving forward
so bannon is trying to claim that he is
now leading the populist movement he's
leading the trumpist movement and trump
is not leading the trumpist movement
only steve bannon can now
again do i like steve bannon no i think
he's a jerk uh
do i think that steve bannon is capable
of doing something like
leading a movement i don't um steve
bannon
from what i know of him and i've said
this openly is a guy who basically has
glommed onto
power for as long as i've known of him
uh he glommed onto sarah palin he
glommed onto sean hannity uh he glommed
on to
dick morris he glommed onto michelle
bachmann he glommed onto andrew
breitbart and then he glommed on to
trump
the idea that that bannon is a is a the
engine of a movement
rather than a barnacle on the movement i
don't think is is actually fair
but what i do actually appreciate about
what steve bannon is doing is i think a
lot of the people who he's actually
backing
are good people and better than some of
the incumbent senators that he's running
against
so bannon is trying to pose himself as
this leader of a movement
which i don't actually think is true
here is him talking about the supposed
populist revolt
uh that is that's in the works this
populist
nationalist conservative revolt
that's going on that drove donald trump
to victory
that drove judge moore to victory that
will drive
15 candidates to victory in 2018
[Applause]
okay so this idea he's had a lot of
words in a row there uh and the words
have no relationship to one
one another populist nationalist
conservative what does that even mean
what does that even mean like i assume
he would he said he would he would back
ted cruz and roy moore and mike lee they
have very different views of politics
those three
the idea that that these are all part of
a populist revolt is not true
basically here's what's happened in
american politics since 2010. there's
been a vast backlash
against obama and the obama movement not
based on race
not even based on excess spending but
based on
a generalized anger at the way that
politics has been done
people feel like they're cut out of the
loop okay the tea party movement started
long before steve bannon was even
involved at breitbart right breitbart
wasn't even around in 2010
when the tea party movement really
started big government was big big
hollywood was but breitbart.com only got
started as one
cohesive website in 2012. i know i was
there the idea that
that breitbart is the moving force
behind the populist nationalist movement
there is no populist nationalist
movement there's a bunch of people who
are tea partiers and who are now voting
for a set of disparate
candidates the way that this is morphed
thanks to trump is that trump was
just the latest masthead on the ship
that has had many mastheads right ted
cruz
was on the masthead originally uh the
then uh
he was at the prowl of the ship in 2012.
i remember because
over breitbart i was backing ted cruz
over david dewhurst in the in the texas
state primary for uh for the senate seat
um
you know the the the it's had other
faces too uh this this tea party sort of
insurgency
the idea that that bannon is the head of
that or that trump
is the driving force in the ship is not
true trump was just the temporary prow
of the ship bannon is not a temporary
proud of the ship whoever is the prow is
the prow
bannon's just a guy who's picking some
people and directing mercer money toward
them
which is fine but i think it's easy to
overestimate the lengths to which
people are going to to exaggerate this
conflict the so-called
establishment versus anti-establishment
conflict these terms have no meaning
that i can spot except for a feeling and
i'll explain that feeling in just a
second but for that you're gonna have to
go over to dailywire.com
for 9.99 a month you can get
dailywire.com
that means that you will get our website
with only the banner ad no more ads it
means that you get the rest of my show
on video live it means you get andrew
clavin's show on video live starting at
10 30 it means you get michael knowles
show on video live
at 12 30. it means that you get to be
part of my mailbag on fridays you get to
ask me questions
it means that when we do the
conversation which is coming up today
with andrew clavin
right it's coming up at 2 p.m pacific
time today daily wires andrew clavin and
alicia krauss are going to do a q a
all of the mysteries of the universe
will be answered when that happens you
will be able to ask a question so it's
going to be broadcast live on facebook
or youtube
but you're only going to be able to ask
andrew a question if you're a member
so for 9.99 a month you can become a
member which is awesome for 99 bucks a
year
you can not only become a member you can
also get the annual membership which is
cheaper than the monthly membership and
this leftist tier is hot or cold tumbler
the greatest of all possible tumblers
take off your relatives and enjoy
drinking
their their bodily well the the safe
bodily fluids they're tears
uh make sure that you can you can do all
of those things with the leftist tears
hot or cold tumbler which is just
awesome or go over later
to youtube but please subscribe to our
youtube channel we always appreciate
that we always have great content coming
out
or go over to soundcloud itunes leave us
a review always helps our ranking we
appreciate it we are the largest fastest
growing podcast
uh on the conservative side of the aisle
in america
[Music]
so the bannon trump thing broke out into
the open yesterday because the idea is
that bannon is on one side primarying
people and trump is on the other side
opposing the primaries
nonsense nonsense bannon has a
particular idea
of and just like a lot of us do by the
way i'm sort of on band inside of this
argument
bannon has a particular idea of who
are candidates who are worth backing in
primaries and mitch mcconnell has a
separate idea of which candidates are
worth backing
in primaries and mitch mcconnell would
have backed david dewhurst in texas
instead of ted cruz
presumably he would have backed whoever
was not rand paul in that primary
um but you know there are differing
opinions on basically who should be the
senator
but that's more an attitudinal thing
rather than a positional thing
it's more of an attitude rather than a
position the idea that mitch mcconnell
is the quote-unquote establishment steve
bannon is not the establishment
you have to show me where they differ on
policy and where they actually differ on
policy i know it's kind of a hard
question and a surprising one
because when you think of steve bannon
you think oh he must really disagree
with mitch mcconnell on policy
does he he encouraged president trump
not to get rid of daca in the first
place
did he differ from mitch mcconnell on
that he and mitch mcconnell were on the
same page on health care
so did they differ on that they're on
the same page
on taxes basically do they differ on
that except the bannon is more left
bannon wants to increase taxes
on high earners do they disagree on
foreign policy
they may but that really isn't the
purview of congress they don't disagree
on funding the military
so where exactly do they disagree this
is why i say it's more attitude than it
is anything else which is why trump is
president and
ted cruz isn't right it's more about the
attitude that best channels the
conservative anger best channels the
anger on the right than it is about a
set of populist nationalist ideas or any
of this kind of nonsense
and what this now comes down to is the
varying personalities now you may have
noticed
that i really dislike the politics of
personalities
i think the personality matters i do i
mean character matters
but i dislike this idea that you back
trump because trump has an attitude but
you don't back mitch mcconnell cause
mitch mcconnell doesn't have the right
attitude
here's the question who's best at
pushing the conservative agenda
some people will say trump i would say
what's the evidence some people would
say mcconnell i would say what's the
evidence
right some people say ted cruz i'd say
there's more evidence for that than
either but
that is not that's the real question
who's best at pushing the ideas that you
want
pushed rather than who is the guy who
most
apes the style that you think is is fun
to watch right who's the guy who punches
and yells or versus who's the guy who's
quiet and talks like a turtle like who
cares i don't think that matters all
that much
unless it has an impact as to the
efficacy of pushing a particular point
of view
the way this is broken down therefore is
you have steve bannon
who's very loud and says a lot of stuff
and
pretends he's darth vader and mitch
mcconnell who is a turtle
and then in the middle you have donald
trump who has
sort of attitudinal affinity to steve
bannon
but who knows that mitch mcconnell is
the guy who actually has to get his
agenda done and that's really how this
is breaking down so here is donald trump
saying
listen we're not getting anything done
but i'm not going to blame me and it's
because trump feels like nothing's
getting done
that he's tempted to blame mcconnell but
we're not getting the job done
and i'm not going to blame myself i'll
be honest they are not getting the job
done
we've had health care approved and then
you had
a surprise vote by john mccain uh
we've had other things happen and uh
they're not getting the job done
right so he's not going to blame himself
so who is he blaming blames mcconnell
and then he would go on to say
that he knows how steve bannon feels
about primary people again it really
isn't about ban and it's really about
mercer money
but there is a danger right so this is
this is the game i'm analyzing the game
here so here is
trump saying that he knows how bannon
feels about about primarying people
depends on who you're talking about
there are some republicans frankly that
should be ashamed of themselves but most
of them i tell you what i know the
republican senators
most of them are really really great
people
that want to work hard and they want to
do a great thing for the american public
but you had a few people that really
disappointed us they were here
so there is trump basically saying he
sympathizes with bannon but then mitch
mcconnell is whispering in trump's
you're going um
president trump if you lose the majority
because we primary a bunch of people who
are going to win general elections
then you're not going to do anything if
you lose the house in 2018 they'll
impeach you
so that is so that's what mcconnell did
they did uh they did a lovey-dovey
sort of press conference yesterday
between mcconnell and trump
attitudinally the two guys couldn't be
more different but trump needs mcconnell
and mcconnell needs trump
and so that's how this shakes out and
that's why you have trump saying that he
likes mcconnell right so this is trump's
new stick is that he likes mcconnell
even though he clearly hates him
my relationship with this gentleman is
outstanding has been outstanding
we are working very hard to get the tax
cuts we will continue to work hard to
get
the health care completed
okay so again this is the reason that
i'm bringing this up is because i think
that the media narrative is not true the
media narrative is its establishment
versus anti-establishment o'connell
versus bannon
that's not really what's happening here
what's happening here is that steve
bannon
wants to be perceived as the head of a
movement that he is not the head of he's
going to pick some candidates like chris
mcdaniel
uh in mississippi who came very close to
knocking off dad cochran in mississippi
and then he will back him mcdaniels
would probably win anyway
uh and then he will proclaim himself
leader of the movement and then after
that
you will see there's a lot of
repercussions is is
a slap against mcconnell it's not really
a slap against mcconnell this has been
part of something that's been going on
for a very long time
it's been about a base feeling that
mcconnell does not fight hard enough
so he must have more senators who fight
harder but it's not about populist
nationalism or any ideological conflict
or any of that it's a little more messy
than that it's about attitude
rather than policy okay quick time for
things i like and then things i hate so
a quick thing that i like um there's a
book that i'm in the middle of right now
that i'm really enjoying by thomas west
it's called the political theory of the
american founding
it is heavy reading okay it's not easy
reading but it is about the idea that
aristotelian ancient thought informed
the founders view of
america this is a pretty obstruct debate
in conservative circles
which is did founding philosophy break
with ancient thought about from
aristotle about the
what man was created for or does it
jibe with that right is the natural
rights theories of the founders
are they disconnected from the idea of
aristotle that human beings have a
purpose
that we can discern or is it connected
deeply to that
in other words our rights connected to
duties that's really what it's about so
thomas west is making the
is is pointing out that the founders
truly believed in duties they just
didn't believe that it was the
government's job to impose those duties
on other people i i agree with thomas
west's general premise
here okay uh time for a quick thing that
i hate because we're running short on
time
the quick thing that i hate is that jane
fonda is back and better than ever
or worse than ever is the case maybe
jane fonda if you recall all the way
back to
the 1960s and 70s she went over to
vietnam and she posed
on a north vietnamese gun that was
actually aiming at american planes
and then she proclaimed herself a
patriot she says she has no regrets
about any of that
and then she says that she is not proud
of how america is today
infamous photograph of you with the
anti-aircraft
weapon i wonder if
still inside you there's a there's a
sense of regret about
i don't regret going to vietnam the
united states was bombing the dikes of
north vietnam
earth and dikes in the red river delta
if the dykes had given way
according to henry kissinger somewhere
around 2 million people could have died
of famine and drowning
and we were bombing and it wasn't being
talked about and i thought well
i'm a celebrity maybe if i go and i
bring back
evidence and it did stop two months
after i got back so i'm proud that i
went
it changed my life all for the good
let me ask you a simple question are you
proud of america today
no okay so i think that you want to know
why again
we don't have to continuously do why is
trump president but this is why trump is
president okay the reason that president
trump is president
is because you have a woman who posed
alongside people who are attempting to
murder american soldiers
and she's saying that she's not proud of
america today if you have to choose
between jane fonda
and donald trump people are going to
choose donald trump it's that simple
okay
we'll be back here tomorrow with more
breakdown of the day's news and politics
will be in tennessee
i'm giving a speech at university of
tennessee knoxville i believe it's sold
out already
uh if it's not you can go over and and
check it out over at the yaf website and
then give you some ticket information
you may be able to buy a scalp ticket
i've seen a few of those on sale
in any case i look forward to seeing all
you there and seeing you then i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
you